This lesson is all about
the world's most amazing number.
And I really mean this.
This is an exciting number.
And it's okay if you don't
get as excited as I am, but
the number we're going to talk
about today really is mind blowing.
And the amazing things you can do
with it are incredibly useful.
And this number has two important
properties that I want to discuss.
One of these properties has to
do with multiplication, and
the other has to do with division.
So let's actually start with
the second property, division.
And let's do that by doing
some division problems.
So can you tell me what is 3/3,
and what is pi/pi?
And also, what is -4/-4?
Enter your answers in these three boxes.
And bear with me, this lesson is
going to start a bit slowly, but
I promise it's going to
get very interesting.